c'est un mec qui rentre dans un endroit
dans un troquet et je voudrais avoir de
whisky s'il vous plaît le gars lui sert
les deux whiskys lamboing puis bois le
2e revient le lendemain et souplesse de
whisky ou skier de whisky qui
comprendrait pourquoi ils lui demandent
de whisky au bout de trois quatre
semaines il dit c'est moi monsieur vous
vous êtes tous les jours ou demander de
whisky demandez moi dans un bus vélo et
le deuxième et vous buvez et nan c'est
compliqué j'étais à l'armée avec un
copain on buvait toujours un whisky à 2
là on s'est séparés on s'est un peu
perdue vue donc voilà pour une petite
pensée voilà je bois de wisques il ok
d'accord et revient un mois deux mois
trois mois six mois plus tard il rentre
dans le bar qui lui dit un whisky s'il
vous plaît médias
j'ai compris sinon moi j'ai arrêté
maurice qui croise david dans le sentier
qui dit dis moi un maurice j'ai un prix
paraît ton magasin et la brûler
l'autriche la semaine prochaine
non ça me rappelle une hausse et un gars
qui croisent son pote dans la rue y
croit son pote et son pote et en sang il
est griffé de partout nous manque une
dans les fracas sa chemise et déchiré
team et frérot qui ce qui t'arrive c'est
quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe n'écoutons
on on vient enterrer ma belle mère l'a
dit mais pourquoi tu es dans cet état
elle voulait pas
un mec qui est complètement fracasse il
a bu fumé il a pris tout ce qui pouvait
prendre il est n défierait il en bas de
chez lui en compte un pote à lui dit ah
bah ouais
je t'invite mon appart un parent de foot
plaisir
il monte avec lui nous assène
l'entraîneur interromprait cesse de
s'allonger
il rentre dans la chambre à coucher et
sa femme au lit avec un autre gars
rentrent ans ferme et dix ans
[Rires]
- gucci mane ta
femme
et ça c'est moi
[Rires]
c'est un gars qui ça c'est un gars qui
rentre tous les soirs chez lui et bourré
il enlève ses pompes et prend la
première il la jette contre le mur pas
dire prend la deuxième par le voisin et
n'en peut plus il un peu plus tous les
soirs papa sur le voisin vient voir
édition moi j'habite à côté je suis
enseignant je me lève à 6h du matin tous
les matins ses deux chaussures je crois
plus
posséder
moi c'est pareil et chabot il n'y a pas
de problème ces bons lendemains hand in
orange amère
pour la deuxième il appose tout ce monde
par terre et l'otiv boeny s'il-te-plaît
jette la deuxième fait quelque chose
la paire maquiller dans un café qui
demande un croissant le serveur lame un
croissant et le goûter excusez moi si ça
c'est pas un croissant aujourd'hui je
suis désolé c'est un croissant d'hier
midi où vous voulez vous semble
oui
c'est quoi la différence entre
1,69 et un chalet à courchevel la vue la
vue
est là demain qu'ils sont en train de
pisser contre un mur dans la rue et au
moment où ils pissent il voit qui a
écrit sur ce mur interdiction d'uriner
sur ce mur il semble des phares de
bagnols ces deux bagnoles de flics à
rien le poti diallo tu fais semblant te
masturber
[Rires]